looking back at your childhood now
could be do you feel like that's what's
made you to the person that you are
today
um
like i think everything about discipline
everything about discipline and every
day
and every day every day like you know
train sleep eat repeat
it's like i think like you guys
understand me like you especially you
mike you guys like one of the greatest
athlete of all times you gotta breathe
it live it
yeah be the champ before you become the
champ we have the lifestyle yes it's
have to become your lifestyle and
everything here in mental you know
everything about mentally you know it's
like like people ask me like uh
when you become champion what you feel
like and i said no in my mind i was
always champion in my mind all the time
when i see someone compete like in my
weight classes and i think okay like
since when i like
you when ufc signed me it was like 2012
2013 14 like that time i would think
about
i'm gonna beat these guys i'm gonna i
can beat all of them you know like
everything about mental
so like when you said mike you have to
be it before you come before you become
it did you knew at one time in your life
could be
that you'd be like literally you'd be
the top of the world not only ensemble
but in the ufc
you know it's like this is not not about
i knew or no this is like uh do you have
a vision that's what i have vision
i have vision like uh all the time i
think about like if not injures of if
nothing happen
like if i'm gonna fight like for example
with this champion i can beat him like
always like my mind think about
like uh
i just oh man i just need to compete
with this guy i really want to compete
with him you know like i remember when
uh anthony pettis fight with uh gilbert
melendez it was like in vegas i was
there like i do my rehab and for my knee
and i and i was very close to cage you
know
and they fight for the lightweight title
and i think like when fight finish i
will think like
these guys these guys people call them
like best in the world and i think i can
beat these guys
and my focus was like crazy you know and
after that
rafael dossanis after like three months
beat anthony pettis
and i was thinking like hey one year ago
i'm rafael dusanas
and i'm here without build and all these
chickens they fight for them my title
you know i was like and but that time i
was injured you know and i was like okay
i'm gonna do everything what i have to
do and i'm gonna come back and i'm gonna
maul all of them and when i come back
like 2016 14 i have injured 16 i come
back
and uh it was like two different khabib
you know it's like when i watch when i
fight dosanos and all these fights
before you before i get injured and
after that i change completely because
of focus what was the focus what do you
what do you think was causing all those
injuries because you've been in the ufc
since what year were you in the usc
how long have you been the usc for uh
since 2012. it's 2012. i know you were
injured for them
yeah you're just for a minute what do
you think it was could be it was very
hard time for me you know i was like
because i cannot compete and all guys
were who i beat they they beat someone
and rafael dosan has become lightweight
champion you know it's like and i think
okay i just have to stay focused you
know improve my game and come back and
smash all of them
[Music]